elimination may ultimately happen for
aaron rodgers on the green bay packers
roster we've talked about the awkward
situation the fact that the contract is
currently constructed allows the packers
to have year to year flexibility so they
could flip to jordan love after this
year if they want to aaron rodgers may
want something that binds the two sides
together for two years so he doesn't
have to worry about whether or not the
packers want him for next year charles
woodson incoming hall of famer defensive
player of the year member of that super
bowl 45 championship team in green bay
he was on cbs sports radio last night
with zach gelb here's what woodson had
to say about the relationship between
aaron rodgers and the green bay packers
i think it's i think it's one of those
situations where
um
you know there's all this you know this
talk you know
you know swirling around him in green
bay
and um
you know i i think it could be one of
those situations where it gets it gets
nasty at some point somehow in the back
and forth between
you know the packers and parents agents
and
and then you know before you know it
somehow the thing gets blown up so
i mean i certainly hope it hope hope
that that doesn't happen
but you know this
you know where there's smoke there's
fire you know what i mean so um this
could be a situation where before you
know it you know somebody makes a play
or makes some kind of offer
you know for aaron rodgers and green bay
can't refuse and say you know what hey
you know what we'll go our separate ways
he wants to be somewhere else and you
know what we'll we'll we're going with
the future of the team
wilson also pointed out plenty of great
players as we know have finished their
careers somewhere else he left twice
during his career so it does happen and
he said he thinks that aaron rodgers
will finish his career somewhere else
and i tend to think the fact that they
used a first round pick and a fourth
round picked last year
packaged them together to move up to get
jordan love
and didn't have those two players that
could have helped them maybe beat the
buccaneers in the nfc championship game
maybe beat the chiefs in the super bowl
i almost think at some level it makes
the packers more determined to flip the
switch
to jordan love at some point i don't
think they did that so they have an
asset they can trade later like jimmy
garoppolo when he was traded by the
patriots they made that move they
abandoned that mantra of our goal is to
win the super bowl now our goal is to
win the super bowl now to go out and get
a guy who would help them be relevant
and competitive later at the position
and
you don't
you don't
do that
and not use it
you've made that move you've taken the
criticism i think it makes you more
determined to use the guy at some point
whether it's 22 or 23. clearly it's not
21 because aaron rodgers was the mvp but
if there's any slippage at all this year
that's when all bets are off for 2022
and that's when rogers could be traded
and jordan love is given the job and i
think aaron rodgers knows it if he
doesn't get a contract that ties those
sides together for 21 and 22
the door is open for aaron rodgers to be
the one walking out
well and it's the same thing that
happened to brett favre when aaron
rodgers came in right it's the exact
same scenario that happened and you know
i've said this all along and aaron
rodgers said the same thing when he was
promoting jeopardy last week was that
the timeline for the packers changed
when he won the mvp award when he
completed almost 71 percent of his
passes and threw 48 touchdowns last year
and won the mvp award because i think
the packers plan was to move on from
aaron rodgers after this year after 2020
this off season and he changed that plan
because he was so good because he played
with that chip on his shoulder after
they took jordan love right mike and
warren moon if we if we go back a week
or two warren mood said the same thing
something very very similar about
russell wilson
in seattle so you think about it we
could have russell wilson aaron rodgers
deshawn watson change teams after this
year going into next year and incre if
that happens it will be incredible three
years of quarterbacks changing teams
unbelievable unprecedented i would say
and i don't think we're going to look
back on it as some sort of an aberration
i think it's the new normal in the nfl
with all these young quarterbacks coming
in with teams embracing what they did at
the college level and having success
right away and that desire to find a guy
that's going to be your future for 10 15
years if you get lucky maybe longer than
that we're gonna see these veteran
quarterbacks churn more than ever before
we saw it this year we saw it last year
we'll see it next year we'll probably
see it the year after
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports